all the gracious words about my work in
my book I'm here to make the case for
squatters which may seem like a kind of
contradictory thing to do in the city
that's so affordable but it there's
actually a way in which it makes great
sense this very site fort mason was
occupied by squatters in the 1850s much
of San Francisco was founded by
squatters there's a great history of
that and in fact in my mind sep tember
27th should be a holiday in San
Francisco because that's the day the van
ness ordinance was passed which
legalized a lot of squatters in the city
so there's a real squatter heritage in
San Francisco and so I think it's very
apt that I'm here giving this talk now
part of what I want to do tonight is
proposed you're going to hear a lot of
things about conditions and communities
that sound horrific and indeed they are
horrific but I'm proposing that we think
about these horrific conditions not in
the way that is normal which is oh how
horrible and how we have to fix them or
throw up our hands and say how horrible
that's not possible to fix them but
rather to look at them as an opportunity
that people are doing their best the
squatters are doing their best to house
themselves in a world that won't provide
housing for them and we have to meet
them halfway so that's my proposal for
what governments world organizations the
UN the NGOs everyone needs to figure out
how to meet the squatters halfway
because they're doing their part
and I'm going to launch into this I'm
going to tonight i'm planning to read
some talk some show some pictures and
then we'll take some questions at the
end i want to start out by reading
something from my book which is
essentially the worst case scenario one
glimpse is enough you have discovered
the famous misery of the third world a
sea of homes made from Earth and sticks
rising Prohm from primeval mud puddle
streets massive numbers of people live
here somewhere between 500,000 and a
million souls many have lived here for
decades but half the residents are under
the age of 16 all old and young new
arrivals and long-term residents live
without running water without sewers
without sanitation or toilets piles of
trash line every alley and Avenue giving
the neighborhood its trademark look a
motley patina of red dirt green mango
peels and the festive but faded colors
of thousands of discarded plastic bags
chickens and goats wander by and scratch
at the heaps for food upon occasion to
reduce the load someone will rake some
of the garbage into a pile push it to
the side or against a mud wall and set
it on fire these smouldering mounds pose
the biggest danger to the community that
the flames will spread to the dry wood
of the huts but what else is there to do
with the trash there's no one around to
pick it up the farther in you go the
more of the community slides into the
stagnant swollen valley on one downhill
slope sewage sluices underneath the pack
of water pipes at a rickety river
crossing a vast store of discarded
plastic bags has bunched up in the flow
back on the main road a man with a
wheelbarrow parks in the muck he's doing
a brisk business selling small
vacuum-packed cardboards of milk
cardboard pyramids of milk another
hustles by his cart filled with cases of
Fanta the bottles Teeter and Clank as he
bounces his Barrow across the scarred
track a fellow in a bloody apron slogs
through with a side of beef on his back
headed for one of the butcher shops
where the meat will hang without
refrigeration slowly drying and
attracting flies as the proprietor cuts
portions for customers with a backfire
in the blast of soot an old-fashioned
gasoline engine throbs to life it powers
what's called a passo mill for grinding
white corn into fine flour destined to
be made into who golly the staple food
here next door a man with an ancient
iron filled with charcoal is putting a
crease in a pair of gray wool pants
across the muddy road under a narrow
awning three men are hammering at thin
steel sheets bending and riveting
forming large carrying cases that can in
the pinch double as tables and in the
midst of all this on whatever piece of
solid ground they can find people have
stoked wood fires some are frying fish
or french fries others are scorching
massive bones over a high heat prior to
boiling them to make gelatin or bone
meal still other small entrepreneurs are
grilling corn over charcoal or selling
bundles of sukuma wiki which means push
the week a slang name for collard greens
or kale because you can buy it for as
little as one shilling a bunch and that
pushes your family through another week
silent Street merchants sit behind their
stocks of greenish red mangos or
modelled plum tomatoes that they have
painstakingly set in small piles three
on the bottom two on top of them and one
precariously on the very top on a piece
of canvas or cardboard to
keep them out of the mud the salesperson
periodically produces a scrap of fabric
and lovingly polishes each fruit to make
it look its best so what we're seeing is
some pretty horrific conditions so I'm
going to show you some pictures of what
I believe are the cities of tomorrow
this is ki bara in Nairobi and this is
what i wrote that little introduction
about and it's pretty primitive another
picture of ki bara
this is Mumbai in India this is the
squatter community in borivali National
Park and this is another view of it
these are sprawling communities and here
is Hasina in Rio de Janeiro we're
looking from the top of the hill down at
the rest of the squad our community and
the high-rise buildings in the
background or a middle-class
neighborhood and this is sultan bailey
in istanbul it's a squatter community of
about 300,000 people so I consider these
communities to be the new urban world
these are the cities of the future and
squatters are building them and why I
say that is because of people like
Julius this is Julius and when I first
met Julius I was at the end of my stay
in Nairobi and I fancied myself an
expert on the city and he was coming
with some friends of mine as we were
traveling to a squatter community across
the city from the one in which I was
living and Julius was bug-eyed he was
looking around like nairobi was the
strangest place in the universe and he
reached out at one point and held my
hand almost like for dear life as we
were walking through downtown nairobi
and the reason i found out later was
because it was his first day in the city
and indeed in this picture which was
taken a couple of days later it's the
little girl that's leading julius around
the community she's introducing him to
Kibera now the day Julia
came to keep era he was one of probably
300 people that arrived in Nairobi that
day close to 200,000 people are around
the world in countries around the world
leave the rural area for the city every
day and if you do the math that's about
a million they have people a week or
close to 70 million people a year and to
put that in perspective that's 130
people every minute so rural to urban
migration is huge and it happens for one
major reason and it's the reason why
Julius came and the reason why all the
people that I interviewed in my book are
squatters there's no money to be made in
the rural area you can have subsistence
agriculture but you can't make any money
to live and squatters come to the city
while I shouldn't say squatters people
come to the city for an economic reason
and they're able to find a job in the
city but they can't find housing that
they can afford so they seize land and
build for themselves and that's the
dynamic that's feeding these vast
communities that I believe are the
cities and the neighborhoods of the
future now overall statistics today
there are billion squatters in the world
and that's almost one in six people on
the planet in 20-30 they'll be 2 billion
and that's about one in four people on
the planet and 45 years from now
there'll be three billion and that's
somewhere between thirty three percent
and fifty percent of the people on earth
the numbers are rising
which is why it's important that when
they come to the city no no government's
building for these people they don't
have the money no private developers
building for these people because they
can't pay enough in rent or to buy and
so they build for themselves and the
kind of things that they start out
building are as I said in the beginning
extremely primitive this is kenya and
these are some pretty rudimentary mud
hut put up some sticks and then smash
mud on it and you have your house this
is Mumbai this man is ready for the
monsoon and he's making sure that he's
going to put plastic on his roof so that
water doesn't get into his hut this is
bernard and zhou who is from nairobi
kenya he says owner actually as what
they call a structure owner he doesn't
own the land but he does on his little
hut and his is in a little better
condition as you can see he maintains it
somewhat better and he's lived there
since 1963 and this is how you secure
the roof this is Mumbai again put down
the plastic and wait it with rocks so
that the wind doesn't blow it away now
when you develop some staying power you
begin to build things like this you
scavenge somewhat better materials this
is in Cocina in Rio de Janeiro as you
can see the owner of this structure has
foraged for tile to put on the roof and
even plastered some of the outside of
what's called up by haka a small Hut
this is a somewhat better Hut that's my
friends sulaymana kaya in sultan bailey
and turkey and that's a pretty decent
the home it's all plastered on the
outside it's got brand new roofing tile
and he's done pretty well with it but it
still is small then you begin to get
more this is back in Rio de Janeiro once
people have the ability to stay once
they see that they're not going to be
evicted they begin to build with better
materials so you see the rebar sticking
up from the building's they're
reinforcing the concrete and they're
using brick to build their houses well
I'll get to that there is electricity in
the community and I'll talk about that
in a minute and this is a larger picture
of Hasina and grab this pointer you can
see that with buildings like this
they're really building up and what
people do is they build their first
story and then they sell the roof rights
to someone else who builds on top who
then sells the roof rights to someone
else who builds on top of that and this
is how the community advances in height
and it becomes the title of my talk was
the 21st century medieval city it
becomes very much in my mind like a
self-built version of the kind of
medieval or Renaissance Italian hill
towns where you get these strange towers
and very convoluted street plans
this reminds me of that so this is
Brazil and then when people get a little
more they even start building in
recreation and this is called the pasado
sketch or a skateboarding or
rollerblading and you can see there's a
halfpipe here that was built in and some
kid took a fall on the halfpipe and
again the building up and up been up of
the houses this is sultan bailey and
it's even more urbanized it's got
streets you can see cars and trucks and
you can also see the way people build is
that they build higher than is actually
lived in so the top floor here is not
yet occupied and they build to a fairly
high style and that's a rather stylish
building with these little balconies on
the edges it's all built by squatters no
one owns the property there they're just
building up I should say that all this
what looks like crud in the front of the
photo there is a mattress stuffing
people air out their mattresses they use
mattresses filled with this material and
then they air it out every so often on
their roofs so I'm standing on someone's
roof taking this picture so and finally
you get squatters who build things like
this this is also sultan bailey and this
is kind of a rather dilek setting very
nicely designed home with a lot of
architectural detailing and a big garden
so given time and the ability to stay
put the squatters really invest in their
communities and their homes
so how do you get around these rather
crowded communities this is rio de
janeiro and this is a typical pathway
through the squatter community it's
called a CO and most of them have they
started out as mud paths up the
hillsides but they've now been concreted
over because there are so many people
living in the community Rosina has a
population of about 150,000 people so
this is an entrance to someone's house
and you can see that they just can't
delievered their building right over the
rock so they're very efficient in how
they do these things in the path zigzags
up the hill perhaps reminiscent of
Lombard Street and it's very narrow and
you run into places where you have to
cut back and it's quite steep this is de
Barra I in Kenya and you can see it's
real busy there's a lot of businesses
going on the squatter communities one
thing that people don't seem to
understand about these communities is
that there's a tremendous amount of
economic activity and if we look at the
businesses here you've got a health
clinic you've got a beauty salon you've
got a general store you've got a bar
you've got another salon and you've got
a church all you know packed in along
this little Main Street people bringing
all these products into the community
are backed up because there's a big mud
puddle down here and they're all there's
only one secure track through the mud
puddle and so they're there waiting to
go through its like the primitive
version of a traffic jam there's another
pathway in capara you can see the houses
are quite close together and you gotta
zip through them this is Mumbai these
are pavement dwellers these are people
who build their houses right on the side
walk this is neighborhood called by Cola
and these people have mostly lived here
for 25 years or more and they build
these wooden structures and you can see
they have little balconies which is
mostly where they sleep and the lathers
go up to the balconies and there are
whole communities that live this way for
as I said decades on the sidewalks of of
Mumbai and back to Turkey this is sultan
daily again turkey the squatter
communities seem to be built in a very
pragmatic planned manner they lay out
the streets and literally you can get a
car to almost every home and this is a
relatively new neighborhood in sultan
bailey called bothell Ghazi so there's a
tremendous amount that's still under
construction again it's all squatter so
this is Hasina in Rio de Janeiro and
again there's a main street running
through it with municipal bus service
now Stewart was asking about all these
wires and what goes on with that I'll
show you right now this is a typical
lamp post in Cocina and they have
whether known as got those which
literally means cat in portuguese but is
the word the Argo for a thief of
electrical power and basically they go
to wherever the main electrical lines
are and they steal electricity and thus
all these crazy wires running off the
pole what has happened wonderfully in
Rio is that the utility recognized
that all these people stealing power
were not necessarily criminals they were
potential rate payers and so they went
to the people in the community and said
we will spend the money to upgrade your
electrical service to give you
completely adequate electrical service
if you take a meter and that's been
going on for the past couple of years
most people in Cocina are accepting that
deal and so now the electricity in the
squatter community is fully up to code
and up those concrete pathways that
showed you in an earlier slide our
utility poles and they're bringing
electricity to every house adequate
metered electricity and people are
paying their bills I should say that in
some other countries it's not that easy
in Kenya if you steal current from the
passing electrical pole you will be
prosecuted and thrown in jail and I'll
get to later on in the talk that
governments have to begin to figure out
how to work with the squatters rather
than criminalize what they do this is
another infrastructure issue and this is
kiara in Kenya and that over there is a
trash fire what do you do with garbage
when the city doesn't pick up your
garbage where do you put it well you
burn it a lot of times and that's what
they do and there's a big danger of fire
in the community because of that sewage
is another issue this is a runoff
channel and sewage channel in capara and
that door there is the door to a pit
latrine people don't have toilets they
have latrines and when the latrines get
fill full and no one has the money to
empty them people use what they are
fully but uncomfortably call flying
toilets and what a flying toilet is
is you urinate or defecate in the
plastic bag and you tie it up and you
fling it as far from your house as
possible and Kenyans laugh when they
describe it as well they're rather
uncomfortable with it and as you can see
these sewage channels get kind of
plugged up with stuff these are actually
entrances to homes so people live with
some pretty degraded infrastructure in
capara this is a river and a lot of
sewage flowing right in between the
houses and this was right outside my
best friend in cabarrus house this is a
sewage creek also getting filled up with
all the flying toilets and other plastic
bags this was India in the community
that I lived in in India had managed to
create its own halfway decent sewage
channels and this fellow is cleaning
them so they have concreted over their
pathways and they've created little
canals for the runoff and sewage to run
through sadly most people in this
community they in stood there worried
about these sewage channels most people
have installed full toilets in their
houses but they don't use them because
they're worried that the waste would
clog up these small sewage channels and
would create health problems so they
were hoping that they would get the
municipality to come in and install
sewers and that hasn't happened even
though there's been a tremendous amount
of middle-class development in the area
around where this
community exists but the government of
Mumbai has never extended the sewers to
this community and there's always the
primitive way of getting waste disposed
of you find this in India and in Kenya
that there are a tremendous number of
pigs that Eli the garbage in the
squatter communities I should just note
parenthetically that I enjoy this photo
because I was walking by and I said Wow
pigs and I turned around I took the
photo and I didn't even see this which
is this wonderful little headless god
statue or goddess statue why it's there
I'm not really sure but you do find
religious icons and symbols in the
oddest of places in India and water this
is how Brazilians bring the water into
their squatter communities into the
favelas there's water pipes running up
the hill basically what they've done is
once they once that got those put all
those wires in and they got electricity
they installed electric pumps and other
gatos went and connected these pipes to
the water main and there are huge packs
of plastic pipes running up the hill so
here they are running across a spring
which is also a sort of sewage outflow
these pipes here are sewer pipes from
people's houses that just drop into the
water running down the hill these are
packs of water pipes and this little Hut
right here contains a pump and basically
you have a tank on the roof and you turn
on the pump when you need to fill the
tank and then the the house is served by
the gravity flow from the tank on your
roof and they're pretty good at building
these systems
my experience was kind of I think a good
illustration in my in the apartment I
lived in I was taking a shower one day
and the water ran out and so I toweled
off and got dressed and I went to see
San Antonio who had built the house and
say Antonio went we went up to the roof
and we looked at the Chi show or tank
and it was mostly full and we were
trying to figure out why there was no
water running in my my apartment so it
turned out that my apartment was a new
addition to the house and it was extra
demand and he had only built his system
to be adequate for the the prior units
that he had in the house so what we he
did all sorts of things he shook the
pipes and he rattled the pipes and he
kicked the pipes and finally what he did
is he went into the kitchen turned on
the water tap nothing came out and he
leaned down and put his mouth to it and
sucked and we heard this gurgling noise
and then water came out so every time my
water ran off I had to go and suck the
pipes in order to get water and sail
Antonio felt very bad about this and he
came to me later and said that what he
really needed to do was to install a
wider gauge pipe and to move the water
tank the water tank was on the level
just below the roof and what they call
the logic logic and he needed to move it
up higher so that there was more gravity
feed and if he did that then I would no
longer have to suck the pipes but I was
going to have to wait because he didn't
have enough money to do that so he would
only do that when he had enough money to
do it so people are pretty ingenious at
this and they make these systems work
and this is another example again the
water pipes running
along the pathway again you see this is
a house and it's cantilevered over the
pathway and you see water pipes running
up from there's a pump in this little
area here and that pipe takes it to the
tank on the roof and this is indeed part
of the tank now there's a subtext in
this photo that I want to talk about
it's a bit of a tangent but it is an
important reality in Brazil porosity mom
English say they I didn't realize that
that was there when I took this picture
and I probably shouldn't have taken this
picture de ma means he'll more helmsman
and prosody Mouse sort of means the the
captain's Plaza a noise is the slogan of
a violent drug gang known as the command
over me do most of the favelas in Rio de
Janeiro are operating points for drug
gangs the reason that this exists is
it's an opportunistic infection it's not
that the majority of squatters are drug
addicts or drug dealers it's that the
government of the city refused to police
the illegal communities and so drug
gangs realized hey we can operate there
and they'll never come so they are very
strong in the squatter community and if
you go live in the favela in rio you
have to be prepared for guys with guns
being around I would come out of say Oh
Antonio's house on certain days and
there'd be five guys with ak-47s outside
my house and they weren't there for me
they were there to police a movement of
marijuana and cocaine most of what moves
through Rio is
is destined for export to the United
States or Western Europe and it's a
situation that the favela doz accept
because the drug gangs over the years
have learned how to be communitarian
they fund programs for kids they fund
child care they build soccer fields they
put in right around the corner from
where I lived in co Xenia they installed
a soccer field with floodlights so you
could play all night and they also make
sure that there's absolutely no street
crime in the squad community so in a
city that can be very dangerous and
there are assaults written about that
happen in broad daylight throughout the
legal neighborhoods of the city there's
no crime in or I can't say no but
there's almost no crime in the favelas
at all and it's a trade-off that the
residents have learned to accept it's
also true that the drug gangs are
probably more honorable and easier to
deal with than the police the police in
Rio are not your friends and you never
want to spend a lot of time with them
and I want to read you a brief thing
about my first run-in with the police in
Rio on tivo samora where do you live the
gun was an automatic and the cop had it
pushed into the crevice under my rib
cage this was my second day in
everything was new it was raining the
kind of rain that isn't really rain but
more like a hundred percent humidity
like thick ooze
emerging spontaneously from every object
it was dusk and the cars the people the
stalls selling pirated merchandise even
the noise from everything and everyone
around me seemed glazed and far away on
jayvo same aura I hardly understood the
question I didn't know where I lived I
had just arrived I couldn't speak the
language although i had my rehearsed my
Portuguese before i left my brain shut
down I didn't know a goddamn thing the
cop pushed the gun harder against my
chest it was a modern handgun the
plastic barrel wasn't cold against my
skin I didn't have a sense of imminent
death I didn't experience any film noir
cliches oj was a mora i looked over at
Paul who was on the other side of the
bus shelter I hardly knew the guy but he
had been living in Cocina for a while
and seemed comfortable there he too had
a gun against his stomach he was
standing like a scarecrow arms straight
out and the cop was shouting at him and
jabbing the gun in his gut on jayvo same
aura my cop shouted again my brain
started slowly be polite show respect
use the third person singular gourville
say i croaked it was instinct pure fear
blind and totally wrong comigo the cop
asked seat conv say i wish i could say
it was intentional I wish I could say I
knew what I was doing where do you live
the cop was shouting and I had answered
this way I live with you
with you [ __ ] with your mother
he didn't pull the trigger instead his
eyes changed and it seemed that a little
light went on in his brain and he
finally realized that this strange
gringo with the shaved head who was
walking out of the favela was most
likely not a VC a dollar drug addict not
a trophy conchae or a drug dealer but
most likely simply an incredibly stupid
white man now convo say clearly he
corrected me still angry not with me
with him he waved his gun at Paul the
cops kept us there for 20 minutes they
made Paul recite the names of the people
he knew in Cocina he went through dozens
of names until he mentioned someone they
knew Jose evaldo the driver for the
city's Regional Administrator that was
when they put away their guns and let us
go and I realized then that there were a
dozen people waiting in the bus shelter
to avoid the rain they were all standing
within a few feet of us none of them
said or did anything and they didn't
even move away from the guns and it
occurred to me that this for them was
normal average ordinary simply effect of
everyday life and it's why many favela
dwellers don't like the police so the
police are not your friends and I had
several run-ins with them when I was
there but it's also true that the drug
dealers are dangerous too and I'll read
you a little bit about that
dusk I walked down to the base of Hasina
it was Saturday and there had been a
street fair along the Camino dos boyed
eros one of the main shopping streets of
the favela now most of the merchants
were packing up the road was greasy with
trampled lettuce leaves and leavings
from various butchers who were hosing
down there cutting blocks it was a
pleasant night and the streets were
crowded at the bottom of the hill in a
wide space known as Largo those poyaud
arrows opposite a Catholic Church a kid
was outlined in the half-light he said
stood next to a man who had set up a
hibachi and was selling skewers of
grilled meat he was skinny with long
blond hair and he was wearing baggy
Bermuda shorts flip-flops and no shirt
across his shoulders was a long strap
that ran down across his concave
hairless chest the strap was connected
to an ak-47 he wore it low like a rock
star right over his pelvis in Hasina the
guys with guns come out at night some
stand the solo sentinels others
congregate in packs of 10 or more a few
have pistols sleek 9-millimeter jobs
that are light enough for kids to stick
in the elastic waistbands of their
bermudez but most carry weapons that
would make even a terrorist or a
revolutionary drool with envy ak-47s
ar-15s m16s submachine guns even
grenades you usually see them on the
streets where the drug trade is active
in locations called Bocas de fumo or
mouths of smoke because of its size
kristinia had many Bocas the main one is
in the valley and there are dozens of
guys with guns there at the Friday night
dance parties but there was another Boca
on the Via Appia one of the favelas main
commercial streets where young men sold
papalote days little paper sacks of
cocaine or marijuana and there was a
boca higher up on the hill a true amor
first street and there was also a boca
on my street where the gunman appeared
two or three nights a week
now when you see them for the first time
the weapons don't look real they seem
like cartoon killing machines with
oversized bent build bullet Clips
hanging off absurdly tiny barrels and
the comic book image is enhanced when
the guns are clutched by pimply
adolescents or moon-faced teenagers who
silently watch as families return from
church or children run by kicking a soda
bottle soccer ball but they're not
caricatures because those guns will
peace pierce a bulletproof vest at a
great distance Valeria Christina who
owns a jewelry and eyeglasses Emporium
came to Hasina because of the guys with
guns she used to live and work in Rio's
ritzy flamingo neighborhood but after
armed robbers assaulted her store and
cleaned out her entire inventory she
closed up shop and relocated to the
favela and valaria christina was frank
about the reason she fled the legal city
I wanted a more secure location she said
cheerfully as she SAT amid the mirrors
and stylish designer frames in her
bright new store in the rest of the city
being assaulted was always a risk she
explained muggings and robberies were
common thieves had even been known to
pull knives and guns in broad daylight
on the city's buses and to beat up
tourists on the crowded beaches for
their backpacks and valuables but in the
squatter communities things are
different if someone broke in or tried
to rob this store she said smiling
broadly they would die now Rio's favelas
are ruled by three drug gangs the
command over me leo which means red
command the tercero commando which means
third command and the amigos dos amigos
friends of friends and in the early days
these drug gangs were very similar to if
anyone seen the movie city of god in the
early days these drug gangs were very
similar to that that is a reality of the
drug gangs in the 80s they were just a
bunch of guys with a talent for selling
drugs and some handguns but they're now
much more organized
and much better armed and the command
over me Leo still controls most of the
drug trade in Rio and when i was living
in casino casino was part of their
empire and they were fairly enlightened
and good guys but i can tell you without
a doubt that this graffiti is no longer
there because since I left her senior
there was a war a bad guy got out of
jail and decided to come and take over
Hasina there were shootouts in the
streets there were people who died in
the crossfire innocent people and ksenia
is now the territory of the drug gang
amigos dos amigos and this is something
that the favela dwellers have had to
live with they also have to live with
shootouts between the cops and the drug
dealers from time to time so it's not
always a pretty picture but people
accept it because first of all the guys
have guns and second of all they do make
the community when there's not a drug
war going on safe and they spend for
public improvements so it is an ever
present reality in Rio de Janeiro and
it's important for people to understand
it and it was important for me to
understand it also I had
you know maybe I'm a bad reporter but
when I got the casino people talked a
tremendous amount about there being a
clandestine graveyard and in the jungle
above the squatter community and great
story right go find it report on it and
I never did I had another beer at the
restaurant or I played basketball with
my friends or I went and did another
interview I did everything that I could
not to go can I say that the rumors were
right and that there was a clandestine
graveyard up there I don't know but I do
know two things one is I took some
friends around the favela and they were
infrastructure experts one was Egyptian
and another was French and they were
fascinated by in one of the main bulk as
they fumo the drug-dealing locations
there's a ten-foot-wide sewage trench it
gives the area its name of Allah which
stands for that sewage trench and they
were fascinated by that and they wanted
to take a photo and I looked around and
there didn't seem to be any drug dealing
going on so I said sure take a photo and
then we went on walking and we were you
know it's a fairly sizable community
there's defined neighborhoods and we
were in a completely different
neighborhood allow is at the bottom of
the hill we were way at the top of the
hill and this guy emerges from the
shadows and he grabs my friend by his
shirt and says why were you taking
pictures of my house and my friend
didn't understand Portuguese so I got in
between and i said i don't i don't know
you where's your house and he said down
there down in of allah which was i
managed to convince him that you know we
were ignorant researchers who were just
interested in sewage but
but that's how they sent the message we
know what you're doing we can find you
wherever you are and they have a network
of Watchers and observers and so they
knew that we took a picture of their
house and the second thing I know is
that if you go up against them it
doesn't matter who you are three months
after i left Rio the most prominent
television journalist in Rio a fellow
named team Lopez was doing an undercover
show about the funk dance parties that
are sponsored by the drug gangs and he
had been given the tip that the drug
dealers were forcing girls to have sex
with them at these dance parties and he
went in with a hidden camera undercover
and disappeared and three months later
they identified his remains through DNA
testing on ashes found in the
clandestine cemetery up in the hills
above one of the squad communities in
Rio so these things exist and you know
when you go in you have to recognize
what the rules are in the community and
it doesn't matter how prominent you are
if they want to come after you they do
it wouldn't have been any insurance for
me that I was American so it's a it's a
reality for people and it's worth noting
that reality in its true shape rather
than trying to gloss over it and say
that it's nothing so any rate long
digression about drug gangs but they do
exist only in Rio though the other
communities I never found anything of
the sort criminality didn't seem to
exist so more other pipes running over
sewage and you can see that tons of
thievery of water so that's how the
community gets its water
in Brazil um there's a tremendous amount
of Commerce in these communities and
it's also one of the misunderstood items
about squalor communities is that people
think they're cesspools of misery this
is the linear shopping mall by the train
tracks in Kibera in Kenya this goes on
for kilometers and merchants selling
everything from shoes to use clothing to
vegetables to printed fabric to all
sorts of things and every so often the
train comes through and people get out
of the way this is toy market on the
edge of Kibera this is a huge market
place this is in the rain but it's a
huge market place for produce and
hardware very haphazard as you can see
most of the merchants here are squatters
most of the merchants live in Kibera and
they're doing a brisk business buying
and selling things those green things in
the foreground are mangoes the Kenyan
mangoes are green and they tend to eat
them somewhat hard with with salt or hot
pepper it's kind of interesting it's
good this looks like a picture of
another sewage outflow in key para but
actually you see that thing on the right
is a hotel yes but what they mean by
hotel is not what we mean as hotel a
hotel in Kenya and in India is a
restaurant and there are hotels all over
the squatter communities of Kenya and
India I ate in many hotels in Kenya and
India didn't eaten this one it was a
little too close to the sewage for my
taste but I do have to say and you know
never got sick from eating in the hotels
and the squatter communities
so the food there agreed with me for
whatever reason this hotel is sharing
space right next to it is a butcher shop
and that's rather common in the squad
our communities to particularly in Kenya
where people like what they call niama
Choma or grilled meat so the grilled
meat will be cut up by the butcher and
then served in the hotel and they often
are tandem like this so there's a
tremendous amount of Commerce and it
goes from rather primitive stuff to
rather fancy stuff this is sultan bailey
in istanbul that's a general store their
bizarre there's a furniture store on the
left-hand side of the picture and you
find everything in sultan daily you find
car dealerships you find hardware stores
you find tons of restaurants there's a
post office it's got you don't have to
leave the community to buy almost
anything and as you can see in the the
building with the bazaar in it there's
actually businesses on several of the
floors so it's like an office building
so there's a tremendous amount of
Commerce and all of these communities
and people are making their money albeit
illegally so here's the question how do
you go from this to this or even this
and just as a parenthesis that's not
Hitler Mussolini that's either Turk
although he is pointing out of town
which some people think is so Tom Bailey
the politics of so Tom Daley are weird
it's a squatter community that's
fundamentalist Muslim and they put up
the statue of Ataturk because they want
to be able to show the powers that be
that they are
kamala lists and secular even though
they are religious but they did put him
up pointing out of town so it functions
both ways now my argument is that there
are two things that need to happen to
get development to happen in squalor
communities the first is that people
need a guarantee that they're not going
to be evicted if people think that they
can be evicted tomorrow or with
automatically by government or by
property owners with no recourse
whatsoever they are not going to invest
in their homes now that doesn't mean
that people necessarily need property
rights there's been a couple of years
ago there was a rather popular book that
was published by Hernando de Soto called
the mystery of capital and he argues
that it would be magical if you just
gave all squatters property rights their
communities with blossom but the middle
picture there Hasina people don't have
property rights and they build and the
far right picture Soltan daily people
don't have property rights and they
build so the determinant here is not
whether you have a title deed the
determinant is whether you know that
you're not going to be arbitrarily
evicted what the legalists and United
Nations refer to as security of tenure
now how that is established is often
unofficial people just know there's no
written guarantee that says that the
favela dwellers in Brazil or the getty
kondu dwellers in Turkey are immune from
eviction they just know the second thing
that people need is access to politics
and the prime example of that is turkey
Turkey has two courts of law that make
life pretty good
for squatters the first is what's called
the gadget kondu law gadget can do is a
Turkish word that's a combination of two
words gauging means night Condor mock
means to happen so it literally means it
happened at night and if you build your
house overnight and the authorities
don't catch you and you're in and it's
considered habitable by morning you
can't be thrown out without due process
of law it's true so that gives there was
this for a long time there was this
cat-and-mouse game there was a police
squad and he stumbled that would go out
and try the seek out squatters who were
invading land and catch them in the
middle of night before they were able to
build and the squatters responded by
using quick-drying concrete and all
sorts of fancy technology to be able to
build quicker and be in before they got
caught and so that's the first law the
second quirk of Turkish law that's I
think even more important is that once
you have 2,000 people in a community you
can petition the federal government to
make you a legal sub municipality so
Sultan daily no one owns all the houses
are illegal no one has permission to
build there so Tom Bailey is a legal
city it has a popularly elected mayor
and a government it has the right to
collect taxes and provide public
services so Tom Bailey has a public
works department it runs municipal bus
service and does all this by collecting
fees from the residents who recognize
that the government is providing things
for them this gives turkeys squatters
access to politics the other squatter
communities that I was in don't have
that same access in Brazil people band
together and form residents associations
and then they broke
are their votes to various politicians
for services and things like that but
they don't have the same ability to
organize politically that the squatters
in Turkey do and in Kenya which is the
far left on this slide people don't seem
to have any access to politics at all
partially it's because most decisions
are national decisions in Kenya even
small decisions about the fate of
communities in Nairobi require Acts of
Parliament and it's politics in Kenya is
the zone of the elite sadly the Member
of Parliament who represents this squad
our community of capara is a rich man
who doesn't live there so representative
politics are awful hard in Kenya I would
argue that the squatters need a lot of
organizing to be able to move forward in
Kenya but we can talk about that more
during the question-and-answer period so
I believe that the future of these
communities needs to be determined by
the people on the ground and these are
the people that I see is the civic
leaders of the future the woman in the
middle is Geeta jiwa she is a Mumbai
squatter she lives in a tent on a
highway median she's lived there for six
years she's very outspoken and given the
appropriate empowerment could be a great
leader for her community across the way
in a slightly better location this is
Cherica gundy she and her family also
live in the tent but instead of being on
the median strip there alongside the
access road of the highway so they have
a slightly better location and she's
also very outspoken about her needs this
is her whole family although my friend
Roger would not forgive me if I didn't
point out the guy in the shiny shirt
and the chino pants that are clean he's
also a squatter but he was acting as a
translator for me so he's not part of
her family he's a taxi driver actually
who lived nearby to where I lived this
is Lakshmi she's a pavement dweller
she's a member of an organization called
the Sluman shack dwellers International
and she although for 25 years she's been
living in this little Hut on the
sidewalks of a neighborhood called
nagpada she's been with the members of
SDI she's been to New York she's been to
Cambodia she's been to South Africa
she's been around the world she's been
to more countries than I've been to and
she still lives on the pavement in her
little shack with her parrot outside
this is a Turkish squatter there were
three old ladies who lived in houses
right next to each other and I knew them
only as Nene which means grandma and
she's very proud of her house and very
proud of her garden and she proudly
posed for a number of pictures for me
she's in her 70s and you know lives in
her gadget kondu house all alone I
should note however that expenses got a
little much for her and so she actually
she gave up having electricity because
it was too expensive for her and so
she's living without electricity uh this
is Richard Richard mu gamma and the
Richard is like the great PR man for
Kiera and Kenya he's a roving street
photographer he makes his money by
taking pictures of people he sells the
pictures for fifty cents a snapshot and
that's his business and I was hoping to
have enough money to be able to pay
Richard to take the photos from my book
but it didn't work out that way and he
was very envious of my minolta camera
because he
felt that it was better than his Petry
there and finally this is the man that I
would like to see be the next mayor of
Rio de Janeiro this is a xeno with his
two kids the kid behind the skinny kid
is not his son that's fairly obvious
zezinho is fruit and vegetable merchant
and he's lived in ho senior for 30 years
he started with a pushcart and he roved
the bacos going up and down these mud
and then concrete pathways selling
vegetables from a pushcart and then he
made enough money to open the kiosk and
this is his kiosk along what's called
the estrada da gávea and he's very proud
of his sons and he makes enough money
that he sends his sons to private school
which is a in rio an important thing to
do in if you want your kids to get ahead
the public education system Rios
education system is very backwards on
the primary and secondary level the
public education system stinks you need
to go to private school but if you do
well on the high school exam called the
vestibule are you qualify to go to free
public university which is better than
going to private university so it's it's
a very strange system so in summary we
pull out my notes here there's no mud
hut utopia alright i'm not in favor of
people living with no water no sewers no
sanitation no toilets no electricity no
one in the modern era should have to
live that way but i do argue that
squatters are doing more with less and
more efficiently than any government on
earth in any development on earth they
mix more mortar and lay more brick than
anyone and the key is to let them
harness their own abilities now in if I
were a prosecutor I would be trying to
show
that what is it motive means an
opportunity that you always want to show
that the defendant had well the
squatters have the motive society denies
them a place to live they need to come
to the cities to make money they can't
get a place to live in the city but they
can't get a job so they seize land and
build for themselves they have the means
because they're willing to labor for
themselves to create the home they want
and they do it in a very efficient way
because they're patient when they don't
have money they don't build when they do
have money they build one wall at a time
and many of the huts that I've shown you
in these photos were literally
constructed one wall at a time when
people had the money what they lack and
what they have to fight for and what we
governments around the world can give
them is the opportunity governments need
to meet them halfway provide
infrastructure and materials and a
certain amount of construction expertise
and the squatters will do the rest so
there's a tremendous amount of capacity
out there in squalor communities and if
we can turn ourselves around from
looking as these communities as emblems
of misery to looking at them as
possibilities and if we instead of
blindly without any quid pro quo
forgiving the debt of developing
countries can say to those countries
yeah we'll forgive your debt if you
provide infrastructure to all your
people if you run water pipes into the
areas where people don't have water that
would go a long way to having these
communities develop and flourish and
become better places for people to live
so that's what I wanted to say and I'd
be happy to take all of your questions
thanks
Rob they've secretly been furnishing me
questions all along years okay past some
lasagna and Kevin is going to we got a
lot of questions in a huge crowd I don't
know if it was the squatter cities or
the medieval angle that brought
everybody out here's one from Ryan is
that the Ryan I know now different Ryan
well while property ownership is not an
option in these squatter cities our
residences still considered private
property in bought and sold and rented
accordingly yes that's the short answer
I guess I should give a little
explanation absolutely people buy and
sell and establish value and create a
marketplace even without ownership so in
the sense they are recognizing
possession and buying and selling
possession rather than buying and
selling property and indeed in a place
like Brazil they've actually created
forms which they showed me which are
memorializing the buying and selling of
possession rather than property and this
happens in almost all of the squad our
communities and people also rent with
the same kind of arrangement so among
the informal economic activities does
that include lawyers or out of these
sort out disputes um they don't
generally turn to lawyers it's kind of a
community dispute resolution mechanism
they just sort of argue with out in
Brazil occasionally they will actually
go to the drug lord and ask him to sort
out the disputes and there are occasions
when they work with the government if
they have to but those are rare because
the government doesn't tend to be on
their side so it's more just they sort
of hash things out on their own and
figure it out this may lead to the next
question from anonymous can you say
something about communication within the
squatter villages they have cell phones
phone
thanks okay not a lot they communicate
the way the old-fashioned way they go
talk to each other the most of these
countries the together phone wire is
incredibly bureaucratic and incredibly
expensive they're jumping right from the
wire world to the mobile world but
mobile phones are relatively expensive
to buy a mobile phone new in any of
these countries cost about 100 bucks and
that's just way beyond the means of most
squatters the only place where many many
many squatters have mobile phones is
Turkey where there's a brisk business in
used or stolen mobile phones and many
many of my friends had mobile phones but
otherwise you know people walk and knock
on doors and go talk to each other and
there isn't a lot of technical
capability within the communities just
kind of a practical question from
nameless who probably is going to get on
a plane and try to do what you did
because they want to know how did you do
what you did and mechanically how do you
go from stepping off a plane to living
in a squadron neighborhood how do you
find a vacancy do you have to explain
why you and American want to live there
do you encounter resistance suspicions
what's all that about well it's it's
kind of six degrees of separation you
send out emails and one person refers
you to do another person refers you to
another person refers to you you do
another person what happened with me the
first country I went to was Brazil and I
emailed I got contacts with all the
people that I could get in contact with
a lot of academics and people like that
no one knew anything everyone was
horrified that I was going to live in
the favela because the strange thing is
that most of the academics who study
them never go to them
it's a sad but true so and finally one
person said to me well there's this
crazy American guy who's been hanging
out in Cocina for a while off and on why
don't you email him and I did and he
said sure come on down um and I had the
trust that he was the right guy so in
the first country I had an American who
was completely fluent in Portuguese he's
now a professor of Portuguese at
Oklahoma University and is going to San
Diego State next year but he was down
there and he was establishing an
Educational Foundation which he's still
raising money for and so he brought me
right into the community and he had some
Street credibility there in the other
countries I had to go there I had some
contacts but I had to go there and live
in hotels for about a week or two before
I could make the contacts within the
communities to be able to move in and I
generally worked through church groups
or agencies that had some dealings with
them but I had to get to the squatters
themselves to be able to find places to
live the best story of that was in Kenya
I show up in Kenya and I my contact
there was a missionary for Mary know who
was working as a lawyer giving legal
advice not filing lawsuits but just
giving dispute advice in a church in the
squadra community of capara and I showed
up and she said great nice to have you
here i'm leaving for a two-week vacation
in Tanzania but here's this guy
Nicodemus I trust him with my life and I
found out later that she hardly knew the
guy but I decided all right he's he's
the right guy he seems to have
volunteered to take me on and in fact he
was the right guy
and he became just an incredible friend
and brother and Ombudsman in in that
time there so if you're open enough to
it and and then he worked with me to
negotiate where I was going to live and
that's often how it worked for me so
that's a sort of thumbnail description
so we have so many questions we were
kind of doing a little tag team okay
asking them so here's an inner
utilitarian question from shells it
looks like what if one wanted to
actually build a home there and find a
place to occupy is that difficult to do
and what do you do how do you go about
it do you have to ask well I it's tricky
I I think initially you didn't have to
ask you just went and did it as the
communities have gotten more crowded
there's become more of a procedure that
you need to go through and you generally
have to I mean in Cocina you actually
have to most of the property is
possessed by someone although not
legally owned and you have to arrange
with that person to buy it in in Turkey
there are some squad their communities
where there's still space and you can
just take it but you do have to make
some arrangements with the neighbors
because you're going to have to live
with them and so they're going to have
to be comfortable with who you are and
what you're doing and sadly in Kenya the
squatters I call them squatters but
they're not really squatters the whole
situation in Kenya is just so totally
corrupt the land is not is is
governmentally owned the government
through a sort of corrupt patronage deal
sells temporary occupation licenses to
rich people who erect mud huts and rent
them to the new arrivals so very few of
the 500,000 to a million people living
in Kibera are actually squatters most
them are renters being exploited by rich
people and the reason why rich people do
that is because it's a great investment
you can build a mud hut for next to
nothing and then all the money you earn
is just gravy so it's a weird scenario I
guess the the idea of how you establish
yourself in these communities varies a
little bit from country to country
depending on the how long the squad our
community has been there there are areas
in India where I could set up a tent if
I wanted to and then there are other
squad their communities where I would
have to work out you know whether that
was going to be permitted because the
communities are more dense thnx here's a
question from Mike Ratner okay great
says i'm a member of Engineers Without
Borders a group of volunteers that were
to develop technologies relevant for the
third world and since members abroad
what problems in the squadra cities do
you think may have technological
solutions if any hmm I'm not an engineer
but personally my thought would be it's
not technology that's the issue the
issue really is infrastructure people
build what they can build and when they
have security of tenure they rebuild and
build again and build again as they have
the money to do it so and as you can see
from some of the slides in Turkey they
build pretty well once they develop that
sense that they're going to be able to
stay and that they've had the money over
time I guess the technology that would
be important would be kind of
infrastructure planning if people could
figure out how to bring water pipes or
sewers into communities and thus some of
the money for designing those kinds of
systems might be saved maybe that would
help the municipalities do a better job
at bringing infrastructure in but you
know I've had some of
arguments you know people want you know
wouldn't the internet make a difference
in squatter communities and it's not
that people don't use the internet if
it's around it's just that it's not
their most primary need their most
primary need or the basic necessities
that we all understand water and sewers
and electricity and those kinds of
things and those systems exist they're
just not brought into the squad
communities by the governments around
them so I don't think sadly I don't
think that technology is the important
solution here